e
everyone uh I apologize for being late
if you would please rise and join me for
Allegiance flag the United States of
America to the rep for it stands
Nation
indivisible
with that we open our hearing on the
retained bail bills I understand we have
someone um today Allison from Chester
please red light is on red light means
go that's counterintuitive to me because
I'm on a lot of boards and okay all
right good morning uh my name is Allison
Welsh I'm from chesher County I have
been the treatment Court coordinator
which is the drug court we just changed
our name a couple years ago since
September
2013 um since its Inception and I also
provide oversight to the behavioral
health court programs which are
alternative sentencing and mental health
court and I know you're specifically
interested in pre-trial programs we sort
of have a hybrid right now I have spoken
several times with our County attorney
Chris mcgoffin who's also interested in
having pre- trial programming expanding
it um and he has a vision for it I can
talk about that later on I will say that
straford is clearly the model for the
state they're also much bigger than we
are um but Carrie Conway does a
phenomenal job they have few more
programs and we do we're doing our best
you know I don't have to remind everyone
here we're very rural community we do
our best with the resources we have so
we we'll never have the census of those
large counties I remember hearing Carrie
say they have 500 people in their
programming if I total like the jail
population people in drug court
behavioral health court programs and
even on pre-trial I wouldn't get to 500
so let me just start with the fact that
of the 10 drug courts in the state we
all follow best practice we're all
evidence-based but we're all completely
different we have different models even
though we try to be the same we
appreciate the funding and we do really
well like for my drug court alone we
have the state funding which is
phenomenal but we also have opioid
funding from the settlement we have the
M funding and we also wrote a bja grant
for our recovery coach because we felt
like that role is a really important
role to have in every team and that's
becoming a best practice and
samama and the nadcp allrise who set the
guidelines for drug courts are now
recommending peer support recovery
coaches on every team and are releasing
guidelines this month hopefully soon so
I'm sure like some of the more important
things for you and I know you're going
to barrage me with questions I'm ready
um are the financials so and this went
up significantly since I last got these
numbers so to incarcerate someone for a
year in chesher County the current cost
and this was done by Cheryl Trombley
who's phenomenal head of Finance at the
county so the current cost is
$68,900 and I know you were hearing per
DM so that's 189 per DM roughly to put
someone out Out On Em which all of our
programs use the EM at the jail and
Captain blasic does a great job there
the rough cost was
2592 which is about $710 a
day and I'll say that she does a sliding
scale so that's different for
everyone
the drug court estimate and I have
estimates for different years per
participant is
14,27 so a significant saving for
putting someone in jail clearly and that
perum is about
3910 Behavioral Health Port
programs and I'm sure you've heard about
the workforce shortage so I typically
have two full-time case managers Who
oversee both programs during coid we
lost one staff member who wanted to work
from home we were all back full-time so
my budgets are a little different so I
have twoyear budgets just so you have
that so uh
2022 the budget was lower because we
weren't at full capacity staff-wise so
that's average per client so drug court
we talk participants behavioral health
court We Talk clients so that average
cost was
$2,820 per client at a pum of
$773 in 2021 when we were fully staffed
it was
$3,725 per
client and
$102 per DM that said the numbers vary a
little bit in the program level too so
those costs probably are more in the
line the alternative sentencing program
was started in 2001 and was the first
problem solving Court in the state um
and so trees tends to be Progressive and
it's very collaborative community so the
alternative sentencing program works
with people with a substance use
disorder and they've been charged with a
criminal
offense the mental health court program
and I couldn't get the exact date CU I
wasn't there with when they started it
started in either 2004 or 5 I reached
out to the former coordinator and he
couldn't remember and that's why he's
not working with us anymore just kidding
um anyway it's an alternative to the
traditional court system it's a problem
solving model and we connect uh
individuals diagnosed with the mental
health disorder and or substance use
disorder to a variety of rehabilitative
services and support networks and I'll
tell you that population is typically
severe and persistent mental illness in
a very complex
population um and then for that program
we do monthly Court reviews for the
people that are in Superior Court and I
know you've heard a lot of testimony
about the
overwhelming number of cases in circuit
court so our Circuit Court judges are
very supportive of the programming but
we've not been able to set up monthly
reviews we're trying and they've reached
out to me a few times so we do have a
meeting to try to see if we can set that
up now that we're fully staffed we do
have both case managers in arraignments
for the Circuit Court um arraignment
days on Tuesdays and Thursdays so
they're um taking in more assessments
typically the judge will say can you
assess them and so I just was reaching
out to my case manager she said she gets
six to eight month six to eight
assessments per month so once again a
much smaller volume than what you guys
have been
hearing um referral to the behavioral
health court programs can be made by
prosecution defense attorney probation
District or Superior Court
Judge they're usually part of the
Criminal Court and they can be pre-trial
as a condition of bail or post
adjudication as part of an individual
sentence uh so I just want to give you
some background of what that program
does and hopefully that's helpful so
when someone comes in the counselors do
a full bioc psychos social analysis and
they're both trained um Judy's and mlak
and our new hired Lisa worth is an mssw
so they fill out a full bioc
psychosocial and then from that they
create an individual service plan that
the client signs off on um and then they
do a myriad of referrals in the
community so they're typically referred
to Community Mental Health Center and so
that again is a little bit of an issue
for us right now we've had a contract
with them for years and when I met with
the executive director and I he's a man
who's brilliant and I respect him Phil
weak he said I can't in good conscience
sign this
contract and what that contract did was
expedited services for people in our
programs so he said he could not sign it
because he was down 38 in stad
so I'm sure this is like you've heard
this repeatedly we have a staff shortage
issue for licensed counselors in the
state um so we in those programs
everyone if you're not insured while
you're before you enter the program
you're certainly insured while you're in
the program before I came on Medicaid
expansion wasn't part of it um so the
cost of the program was much higher for
the county since Medicaid expansion has
taken place are costs for the program
which is why the cost that I gave you
earlier per client is down significantly
so we used to have to pay for treatment
for clients so now all of our clients
are covered by either Medicaid or some
form of Medicare as
well um each client gets full Case
Management Services each week they come
in uh they're referred for employment
services educational such as high set
tutoring vocational training parenting
classes giving housing assistance and
there's a pilot program that I created
with Keen housing for initially
treatment court and now we've expanded
to Alternative sentencing not yet mental
health court and it's a voucher program
where participants or clients pay 20% of
their rent up into a certain amount so
that's a new program Keen housing's been
phenomenal with that the case managers
work on helping get clients Med
stabilized they do a full money
management plan budgeting and we have
Housing Programs we work closely with
the shelter city of keen 100 nights
Southwestern and we also if they don't
have phones or can't get phones through
SafeLink part of our budget has been
providing phones and phone cards
especially during coid when all of our
treatment was tellah health and case
management was tella health and
transportation I'm sure you've heard
transportation and housing are the
biggest barriers for everyone especially
in rural communities like us there's a
wonderful man in Dublin New Hampshire
who has a program peace for B bikes
bikes for peace sorry Jeff um Powell and
he has donated so far about 20 bikes in
the last couple of months that's not
going to be great for the winter but
it's been incredibly helpful we also
provide bus passes but the bus has a
very limited route I am on a local um
mrcc which is trying to expand
transportation in our community working
closely with Mobility managers through
through
Southwestern the program also has
randomized UA testing we do with a
center
um I think I've already gone through a
lot of budget numbers with you just so
that program typically like if you are
flawless and perfect which we don't
expect it's 90 days but we have people
in that program for two to three
years um we've had a lot of success and
I know you're more interested in
pre-trial so I'll tell you like in 2022
31 people were pre-trial 15 were post
adjudication for the mental health court
eight were pre- trial and five or post
adjudication for um the alternative
sentencing and
2021 27 were pre-trial and 36 were post
adjudication so for this current year
which still is not resolved um we have
to like right now 13 clients active in
those two programs 35 since the
beginning of the
year 14 clients have successfully
completed the program so it's a 64%
completion rate eight have been
discharged and I'll tell you that they
get lots and lots of chances for
someone's discharged similar with drug
court it takes us a long time DET
terminate someone in 2022 there were 49
clients
15 24 successfully completed the program
so it's 73% rate which is great I'm
hoping that we get back up there nine
clients were discharged and one client
sadly passed away and I can continue on
those numbers I don't know I know you've
heard a lot about drug court I'm not
sure how much you want me to go into
drug
court only as much as it uh deals with
pre-trial or so the drug court model is
post adjudication Okay so no not at all
yeah so um I'll tell you that uh it's
post adjudication and I know some people
spoke of other tracks so we are
high-risk high like everyone else around
the state the only one thing we do
differently and we've only had one
person take advantage of this is if it's
your first felony offense and you
successfully complete the program you
will not get a felony
record but it's kind of hard to hit high
risk High need and not have several
felonies most of our population has you
know about 5 10 page WRA sheet uh a
little background on me I was a
prosecutor in Manhattan and a public
vender in Oregon so I was a lawyer many
many years ago so I have a criminal
justice background not clinician not
clinical at all so uh we are fortunate
in the sense that we have a lot of
funding um from the county we also have
a friends group they initially were the
friends of cheser County Drug Court we
changed our name to treatment court and
then when I started to oversee the
behavioral health court programs they're
now the friends of chesher County
Recovery Court programs so they provide
us with a lot of incentive funding we
have a contingency Management program in
the um behavioral healthc programs that
they fully fund they provide incentives
they provide phones they've delivered
food for people for us for when they had
coid and they're super supportive they
also we've had um Chamber of Commerce
presentations reduced stigma around
mental health we another one coming up
November 13th in cheser County so it's
community members Allison if I may it
not not to interrupt you but it's what
you're speaking of specifically the the
behavioral health that you're you know
you're kind of mentioning like
scattering a little bit and I know I
speak for pretty much every member of
this committee when I say we are hearing
so much about that every single day and
one of the things of course being from
cheser County I've been saying we we
have this we have this we have this and
I was talking with Chris last week and
he had mentioned that and correct me
where you can if I'm wrong here that the
state did adopt it it was almost like a
grant program and that chesher County
grabbed hold of that several years ago
and then made that be what it is today
so one of the questions we're hearing so
much about is you know State unfunded
mandates could you talk a little bit
about how it was that chesher County
came to adopt this behavior health
program and how and where it is today
because of that so yeah that happened
before my time so I've been there since
2013 I know that uh we're a very
Progressive County and a lot of people
were not thrilled with the incarceration
rates and our incarceration have gone
significantly down so they did create
programming a lot of the sentiment in
the county is to get treatment provide
help beforehand so you don't continue
incarceration tell you the most
frustrating thing in my role uh I
received a lot of calls when I first
started about people wanting to get
their children in drug court and I said
unless you want them to go out and
commit about 20 crimes I'm never going
to see them but a lot of these programs
developed because you couldn't get
access to treatment so we had to develop
relationships with the community mental
health centers with local treatment
providers to create access I mean a lot
of the crimes kept happening because
they were drug rated so the program has
expanded over the years years to get
access to treatment get access to
medications and to stabilize individuals
community so basically there was a lot
of
advocacy there was a lot of advocacy
between the leadership of the county and
then the various cap programs that the
county has and like the drug court
funding a lot of the programs started by
federal funding sure and then became
incorporated into the county and the the
youth the youth
diversion program I I know we we've you
know we speak of that a lot whenever
we're in our executive County for those
of you that don't know I'm obviously in
chesher
County um we speak a lot about the youth
diversion program and I've talked to
several people that have had children
that found themselves in some kind of
trouble and it it could have been
detrimental and that that path put them
right again if you will would you do you
have any information that you could
speak a little bit about that that's
funny CU I asked her to come speak last
week and she said there was some
representative from the program so I've
met with Alissa Bender I don't deal with
juveniles at all but I will say she's
phenomenal I mean while she's in that
job she's getting a master she's
expanding programming access she is very
involved in the community unfortunately
she's not affiliated with the county she
works at um so I don't deal with her but
I have met with her because she does
phenomenal work and I was on a youth
Coalition for a while and she was a
member of that and she does great things
with the youth maybe that's why our
numbers are down I but uh yeah I would
reach out to her if you have more
questions about the Juvenile Diversion
program but she does a phenomenal job
that um thank you can you um would you
tell the committee a little bit about um
how you you used the electronic
monitoring you said to good success how
do you who oversees it and who has the
authority to pull somebody in if they're
violating their their bail conditions so
Captain blasic unfortunately she's in
Jamaica right now because I was calling
her before her flight uh she oversees
the program and um we don't typically
let me take a step back by saying that
in treatment Court we don't have a lot
of people upconing I know you've
discussed a lot of failures to appear I
think because we're such a small
community and like Keen is our city um I
guess I shouldn't do air quotes uh Keen
is our city and so the KPD know all of
our population like I can run into
anyone on the street andless say have
you seen so and so so like I can tell
you that for me as far as absconding
I've had two names on my list for like
six years but I know by going on
Facebook one's in um Vegas and the other
one's in Alabama and he actually just
reached out to try to clear it up so
people don't really leave where we are
it's a small sort of very tight-knit
Community Captain blasic does em for the
jail so the probation does not provide
electronic monitoring so Captain blasic
has been doing it for several years and
she does have a standardized checklist
of who's appropriate I know they've
expanded it because the number of people
higher like there's several people that
are out on em I thought I had that
number with me I can get you that
number do you use it um strictly post
sentencing or do you use it to monitor
um people who are pre-trial so they have
several that are pre-trial okay and but
that's not a decision that I'm a part of
because I don't deal with the bail
Commissioners or bail at all okay do you
know who sets those who who who um who
imposes that condition is usually the
court yes
okay and you spoke about the Medicaid um
we've heard that Counties have had a
difficult time getting reimbursement
unless someone is admitted to a hospital
have you found a way around that to get
Services um reimbursed so that's a jail
issue yeah and um it's a phenomenally
bad one for the jail because they spend
a lot of money yeah I know that the jail
did just receive an mud Grant to cover
some expenses and some mat expenses so
medication assisted treatment and so I
know they receiv received that but as
far as their medical bills no and um I
know someone else testified that once
someone's in a hospital and in then
that'll be covered but yeah I was
working with Doug ywe for years trying
to figure a work around I mean that' be
wonderful if Med medical expens and
while incarcerated were not cut off yeah
it seems that there's a two systems
working against each other the insurance
companies are incentivizing the
hospitals not to admit and if they don't
get admitted then Medicaid won't pay the
state or the county back for the
expenses so it's it it's going to need a
federal fix unfortunately I think
definely we'll certainly be advocating
for that any other questions from the
committee members represent Stone thank
you under your program do you also have
individuals that are being supervised by
either probation or parole department of
the State of New Hampshire so yes so for
treatment Court once and this happens a
little bit differently around the state
so when you plead into the treatment
Court program also known as drug court
you are um agreeing to five years
probation so we have uh probation
officer on our team and he supervises
them for five years uh that's reduced to
3 years if you successfully complete the
program and in Behavioral Health it's a
mix if they're post adjudication and
they're sentenced to probation then yes
but not everyone who's in behavioral
health court programs is on
probation
followup and I take it there's no
reimbursement from the state to the
county to offset those costs is
there uh so um for the treatment Court
we don't pay for that supervision it's
just part of the
so representative wheeler thank you um
so people who don't have insurance when
they come to you you can get them into
the Medicaid or Medicare program
whatever would be most appropriate for
them for all of our programs that's
required okay um especially for a drug
court because we have treatment
providers now our treatment providers
are online and they bill
Medicaid so yes it's required for all of
our programs follow y when did that
begin uh they had Insurance I've been
okay anybody else have any followup
questions we all set well thank you very
much for driving here today I sure do I
do know how far it is and um I will
certainly reach out to um to to Chris if
I have any further questions and while
we're here I would just like to take
this opportunity to tell everybody to
tell everybody that is is thinking about
these program if your county doesn't
have them or if they have some of them
but not all of them reach out to your
delegation we're all members of our
County delegation reach out to your
executive delegation reach out to your
Commissioners start the conversation and
make it happen because it can happen and
it and it really does great things if I
could add one more thing sorry um we
also have a restorative justice program
yes uh that's um overseen by Patrick
henahan and he was originally in the
victim Advocate because I was on his
hiring committee and now they've created
a separate program so he goes into the
schools goes into the jails and is
creating programs aora of justice and
he's working with some of the people in
behavioral health court as well so we're
constantly trying to expand our
programming but would love a robust
pre-trial Pro program for sure I have
these pamplets about some of the
programs if you guys would like those
and I have other P pamplets I can send
you so the the documentation that you
were looking off of earlier I don't know
if you have that in a you know if you
could email us that and then we could
print it off for people to be able to
look at the numbers if you have it if
you don't um the other thing I was going
to ask if we could make a copy of it but
I don't want to you know put you out or
make you uncomfortable if you're not
doing that comfortable with that I can
I'll send you my notes I mean all is is
just sort of notes kind of random that
would actually be very very helpful us
thank you very much I'm sorry I miss
muffin day I I know oh if if you don't
mind representative Harry gther yes um
what was the person's name Patrick
Patrick henahan how do you spell that h
I tried to get him up here is is that
the restorative justice know so the
restorative justice
program speaking a little just a little
bit about my understanding is first of
all the the victim in the crime does not
have to agree you know to the program it
is it is between it is between the
victim it is between the the perpetrator
and you know we do we have seen my
understanding is we have seen success
with it but I don't want anybody to
think that that is something that that
the person that has been wronged has to
do right one of the things we always
talk about is you know the the victim
never being blamed for the crimes that
were committed against them but it is a
nice option that they have and you know
we have we have seen positive results
with it so we're kicking butt down there
all right anybody else we're all set
thank you again
thanks so we are going to um we have
some members of the public that have
reached out to to uh the chairman and
myself that is going to talk with us in
just a few minutes and we're just going
break
leave for a call um at this time I
believe we have some someone here from
the community who wish to testify from
uh Manchester I believe
please Lopez I have a seat and turn on
the mic thank you my name is Jesus Lopez
can you hear me yep okay so let me just
tell you who I am I was born and raised
in the Bronx my mother mother had me
when she was 13 when I was born my
mother was 13 years old um I grew up in
a broken family filled with
drugs uh
violence no structure nothing um I came
to New Hampshire
1993 when I came to Manchester New
Hampshire in 1993 from New York
City I thought I thought I went to
another world because in '93 there was
no drugs there was hardly no homeless
problem Manchester was a beautiful place
okay and I did come to Manchester New
Hampshire for the wrong reasons and I'm
going to get to that but the reason why
I'm here today is because um a lot of
the things that we're doing in my
opinion is not
working um and I know some people will
agree and some people won't agree so to
those who don't agree with me what I'm
about to say is what I'm going to say
first have you ever smuggled drugs
across state lines have you ever
packaged drugs for sale have you ever
lived in a poor Community like that have
you ever been to prison have you ever
had to deal with any of that chaotic
stuff and if the answer is no then we're
all due respect from the bottom of my
heart then I'm sorry you don't know how
to fix this problem okay it would be the
equivalent of asking me to go into
Suburbia world and try to fix a problem
up there I don't know I don't know
anything from there I'm not from there
I'm from I'm from what they call the
ghetto or the hoods or bad
areas
prison reform Bale reform is a joke I'm
tell you that right now and this is
coming from my ex drug dealer I did 10
years in prison in federal state prison
not proud of it but B reform doesn't
work it's a joke
um you know you have people I know a lot
of officers in
Manchester that say say to me you know I
can't even finish my paperwork and this
guy or girl is already walking out the
door you know and and and committing the
same crime two hours later I'm chasing
him around the city again so that's not
working um B reform is not working at
all we need to we need to go back to
what it was here's the big one minimum
mandatories if you're against that you
don't want to fix the
problem bottom line straight up and this
is coming from a person that at one
point I would never speak this
way minimum mandatories whoever thinks
blowing people's heads off and putting
him in jails and and burying him into
the jail is not the answer oh you can't
do that then again sorry with all
respect you don't know how to fix this
problem I'll tell you what brought me to
new ham and what brings and what brought
me to New Ham 30 years ago and it's
still bringing people here
today I came here to I came here in
1993 because again remember the life
side I told you I came
from some guy came to me and told me hey
that piece of crack that you're selling
for $3 you get $30 for that in New
Hamshire I was up here that same week
never went
back so what's happening is that you're
getting a lot of drug dealers 95 96 97%
of your drug dealers are not from the
state they're from out of state they
come here because their kilo that cost
$20,000 in their state is a 100,000 here
and we're not doing nothing to
them they're getting caught and they're
being
released there's no punishment for them
there's nothing
so again you know we need we need
minimum mandatories you want to scare
away a drug dealer um this is the next
drug dealer you're looking at you're
going to scare them with minimum
mandatories if they know they're going
to come to New Hampshire and get put
under the jail for selling drugs they're
not going to come here they're going to
choose another state why you think a lot
of guys don't go to
main a lot of Street guys don't go to
Maine Maine will bury you in the jail
so if you think that minimum mandatories
don't work you do not want to fix the
problem period and I'm tired of burying
close friends of minees family members
because nobody wants to fix the problem
this is this is not this is this is not
going to fix the whole problem but it's
going to fix a lot of it your secret
secret indictment program is a joke is a
joke people on social media are reading
that XYZ dealer got arrested at 4:00 in
the morning
but there's no you know you got you got
to let your presence be felt do like
they do in New York TNT buy and bus
sting operations you don't sell let
somebody sell to you and then you come
get them at 4 o'clock in the morning
where the public and the community
doesn't see this they don't see this out
of sight out of mind the police don't
care the state don't care they're not
doing anything about it but if you do
TNT technical narcotics task force buy
and bust operations br broad daylight
where the agent goes down makes the buy
as soon as he makes the buy he's walking
away blue hat red shirt blue jeans blah
blah blah screeching tires boom boom
boom all these guys jump out law
enforcement jump out you're letting your
presence be
felt to the community you're sending a
message to the community hey we're here
for you and to the drug dealers we're
not playing around no more the way
you're doing everything now doesn't work
I'm sorry I'm so so sorry to tell you
that um another thing that I want to say
was uh you know I feel bad for the
addicts I come I come from a family of
drug
addicts but we could write legislation
in this in this state and I guarantee
you other states will follow we could
write legislation in this state just
like Robert Blakeley wrote the RICO
statue we could write a statue in this
state that applies to uh uh opiate
dealers and we give them and and and
those opiate dealers we bury them in the
jail oh how do we how do we sort out
who's an opiate dealer and who was a
poor addict that was getting somebody
from somebody for somebody else so that
they very easy very simple to
do in the booking process when they are
arrested for sales of we we we we write
legislation we we we make this law okay
that applies to drug dealers not drug
addicts drug dealers how we decide for
the two well one we can tell by just
looking at them number one but that's
not a good way to do anything this we
have we need
confirmation so how we get confirmation
in the booking process fingerprint mug
shot you're not a dealer no you're an
addict piss in this cup at the time of
arrest in that cup if you don't give me
a positive for opiates you're not an
opiate you're a dealer you're not you're
not an addict and I don't care if you
give me a positive for cocaine or
marijuana because I know a lot of
dealers that do cocaine and do
marijuana opiate and and if you're and
if you are a true Opia addict then that
releases you from the new from the new
law that we would write that would put
you in jail for a decade at
minimum you want us you want to make
change that's where you do this is where
we start this is how we start this
otherwise I'll tell you what your kids
your grandkids are going to be here 20
30 years from now talking about the same
problem you want to really do something
this is how you do it this is coming
from a I who once lived that side of the
tracks there was a time in my life you
couldn't pay me to come here and talk to
you
guys because I changed my life I was
once illiterate I couldn't read I
couldn't
write I didn't I I didn't I didn't
growing up in the Bronx I didn't have
education I I think my highest grade
completed was sixth
grade you know and so all the things
that I was taught from when my grandma
passed away I didn't have no more I was
a I was a man at 13 years old I had to
undo all those things because they were
all wrong and I realize that today and
I'm trying to help you guys to help
everybody else in the community addicts
alike because I come from a family of
addicts and um the addicts we need to
start treating them like addicts give
them an alternative to incarcerations
give them empowerment so they could
build themselves up from the inside
out you understand and we got to have
real true care in this too it can't just
be on the surface oh we we're going to
sit here and just say we're gonna do
something we got to really do it and and
it's got to be full full care and I'm
sorry for the drug dealers that come to
New Hampshire send a loud clear message
you come to the state to sell your crap
we're going to bury you in the jail end
the story you'll see a decline you'll
see a decline whoever says again I'm
sorry we're all due respects to everyone
please whoever thinks this doesn't work
minimum mandatories you don't know what
you're talking about you never lived on
my side of the tracks you don't know
what scares us well I should not us
because I don't live that life no more
but you don't know what scares that
group of people drug
dealers
and again the only way to know that is
you have to have once partake in all
that whole life chaotic lifestyle which
I did so I I in all fness I think I'm
the guy to give you the greatest ideas
how to fix this or how to put the hammer
on this
problem you know um I I want to thank
everybody for bringing me here for
letting me come here um I called and I
was trying to get here I was just trying
to call everybody I could and finally
they gave me the okay to come here
because I needed to address this to
everybody you know uh there's a lot
because I know there's a lot of
people um I hate to say this but a lot
of democratic parties don't believe in
minimum mandatories and that's that's
not true you're
confused sorry you are confused in that
point minimum mandatories will send a
message to drug
dealers they's start doing something
about it because it could be your child
next to die from from an overdose from
that very same drug dealer that came
from Massachusetts or New York or New
Jersey or
Philly could you tell us more about what
you're seeing in your neighborhood
whereabouts do you live I live in
Manchester I live so I live I live uh
655 chestn street so it's kind of okay
area but I spend a lot of time in the
Inner City because I do I take out lead
based paint for the city of Manchester
I'm a contractor and I take out lead
based paint so I'm always in the city
and not only that um I've been involved
in in in in this I I mean in 2016 and 17
for two years straight I was helping
people detox in a garage this size I had
bunk beds in
there um and and and and I'm seeing a
lot of drug dealers coming from other
areas there's a lot of drug dealers that
come from other states you know and they
come here to do exactly that because
that's just it you know if if if they
can spend $5,000 in their state in the
state they live in and they're only
going to make
$10,000 they'll do it but if they're
going to spend $5,000 on drugs in their
state and bring it to New Hampshire and
make
$50,000 they're running to this border
they're running here the they're going
right to Manchester Manchester's the
Manchester's The Hub okay and then from
Manchester that's where they they
realized oh my God where in in in in in
um North Conway or over here or over
there or in Dover over there over here
and then they start to spread
out but your drugs ultimately come and
they hit that when they come up here
they hit Manchester Prim number one and
or the Portsmouth area because 95 comes
up that
way okay
so so these guys that are bringing this
stuff up
here you want to you want them you you
you want to deter people break their
backs in the courtrooms you gotta you
got to do minimum mandatories you know
even on a first-time offender I don't
care right legislation a decade minimum
mandatory you know why because when he's
in jail all his friends man they gave me
10 years up here they gave me 10 years
these they gave me 10 years
every the world's going to go around you
know before you know it people going to
be like you can't go to Noam should to
sell drugs they got minimum mandatories
up
there could you um could you address the
the public perception as far as you're
aware of the bail system now if you get
arrested what's going to happen to you
yeah I've seen it I've seen it a lot I
watched the news a lot which I shouldn't
and and and and I'm involved in the
community a lot which which I'm trying
to change it but I'm one person it's
like I'm fighting a monster with
multiple heads the minute I I'm gain I
think I'm gaining speed or something
it's like five heads come on and bite me
everywhere so what I mean by that is
like I see crimes going
on
and uh the person that commits the crime
is out within two hours three
hours and later on that night or the
very next day getting arrested for the
very same
thing you know and it takes three or
four times before they before somebody
before the prosecutor tells the judge
hey uh you know uh why don't we do a
preventative
detention preventative detention I've
never even heard of that that's a joke
it's it's give him bail or no bail
period you know
uh just I just feel
that you could do a lot better
especially with the with the you want to
drive the drug dealers out get rid of
get rid of your secret and diment
program get rid of that and do TNT
technical narcotics task force buy and
bust operations in broad daylight where
everyone can see it you're going to send
a public I mean going to send a message
to the public you're gonna you you I I
believe I believe it's only my
perception of this if the community
starts to see this it will build it'll
build a closer relationship with the
police
department because out of sight out of
mind the cops don't care they're not
doing anything the people that sell
drugs they're all they but if you're
doing it in Broad daylight in the
community seeing this I I think it
restores a little bit of Hope in them
that you guys are cleaning up the
community and stuff like that I live in
these communities that's what it would
do to me if I saw that so living in that
community and I ask a lot of people if
you if you saw them coming out with the
jumping out grabbing everybody who sold
the drugs bro they like would that
restore your faith a little bit and I
and I get a smile a lot I think it would
yeah it would I would love to see them
do that it always brings a smile from
somebody I've never once seen somebody
unless they're a drug dealer which I
don't ask them they'll be like no way I
don't want to see that but everybody who
is a citizen that lives around the unry
area who doesn't involve themselves in
drugs that have ACC these questions to
would you like to see that'd be nice
right if they start doing that oh my God
what are we waiting for we're waiting
for you
know we're waiting for more and more
people to pass pass away for the problem
to get bigger and bigger and bigger it's
going to get so much it's going to get
bigger you're going to you're going to
need the feds to help you again like you
did in 95 and
96 you had to call the feds to come help
you to do operation street
sweeper you
know
um yeah I really thank everybody for
bringing me here letting me say what I
needed to say like I said um there was
there was a time in my life I would
never speak this way I would never speak
speak this way there was a time in my
life but you know again I was taught the
wrong things growing up as a kid so I
had to undo all of
that and I did a little bit late but I
guess late is better than ever and today
um thank God you know I don't I don't I
don't even dream about that life style I
have a small business I do a lot of work
we take out we K keep kids safe from
from let paint
poisoning and that's what I focus on you
know and I try to keep I don't even help
people detox anymore because I lost hope
so now my all my all my energy goes on
trying to save the kids there's a
there's a nice program in Manchester
called my turn and I try to reach out to
those kids there crime deterrence and
prevention I got a guy who's a
professional boxer he's going to start
training the kids in there burn up some
steam or whatever and just you know but
back to minimum
mandatories uh uh TNT buy and bust
operations and uh and uh bail reform I
think we need to need to look at that as
a government body you guys need to look
at that Democrat Republican independent
doesn't matter get together all of you
guys get together as a team and and and
and turn this whole thing around not
just for you guys but for all of us for
everybody you know we're all one person
away from addiction period one person
and before it takes somebody that you
care about let's try maybe it already
did maybe I'm speaking but you know
let's try to tighten up tighten up that
knot and get the drug dealers and lock
them up
and thank you U any questions from the
committee for this witness
representative Stone thank you from your
experience in seeing people on the
streets using narcotics the low-level
street level dealer in attic are they
safer on the inside or are they safer
incarcerated the low level addicts again
low-level addicts need they they don't
need to be in prisoned they need an
alternative to incarceration in my
opinion because
so here's what they say they say that
and it's proven through science you know
so they say that people who do these do
this heroin and all that
stuff you know people are broken and I
guess when they everybody's broken to a
certain degree I guess that when they
take that substance it it fills that
void it makes them feel happy and
everything's okay and so that's what
they get stuck on that
feeling but before long they have and
I'm preaching to the choir you guys know
this before long they have a two
problems now now you're chasing The
Happy Feeling that you got the first
time you did it and now you got a
physical dependency three days four days
later so I think they need they need
they need uh alternative to
incarceration not to be with a 10year
minimum mandatory that does that's that
wouldn't be fair to them because they
are suffering they're trapped in
addiction and they need uh Alterna to
incarceration need mental health
services and stuff like that because
that's a lot of that comes from mental
health too being broken inside I'm
broken inside I know and
um mental health they need alternative
to incarceration the ones that need the
minimum mandatories are the ones who pee
in that cup in their booking process and
they don't give you a positive for any
um uh uh opiates because those are the
true ones the ones that don't give you
a positive piss test for opiates those
are the true dealers those are the ones
that are taking the money buying houses
Mercedes-Benz this that those are the
real that's the that's the real enemy
right there that's the real enemy and
those are the real I don't want to use
that word Killers I don't know but those
are the ones that are really people are
dying left and right it's de it's their
problem it's their fault you know uh I
could get bigger than that bigger than
therefore I could go to a government
level you know attack the cartels right
but we're not we're not we're not
government right over there in DC we're
here in
mamire but um the ones who are not
giving you a positive urine test at the
time of arrest for opiates then you
don't then then then you will trigger
the new law or the new statute that we
write that we will give minimum
mandatories to anybody selling vetor
anything that has to do with OPI I don't
care bury him in the jail and you'll see
within a few years you'll see a
decline
guaranteed what is the um what is the
most common drug if you're aware of
that's currently going around Manchester
f um we've heard that there's other some
kind of other drug that's causing people
to break out in sores it's a Well is
it's it's it's it's it's fanol and then
then then they have it's Fentanyl and
then the the
methamphetamine so I think what's
breaking making them break out and
everything is that methan fenine because
when they cook it over there in Mexico I
watch documentaries on this stuff all
the time and I'm not a pro I'm not a pro
but I just what I know they cook it over
there in these 55 gallon drums in Mexico
and they wear you should see them they
wear these T they got documentaries on
this stuff they wear these tyvex suits
and full face mask with and and some of
them even wear um provided oxygen and
they mixing it in these big and they're
mixing all these chemicals so these
chemicals putting it into the body so I
think that's what's causing that but
it's not it's not like crocodile or any
of that stuff that's was no it's not
that that's not on the streets what's
out there is mostly fentanyl because
they did away what happened
was so heroin back way back in the 80s
you can take one kilo of heroin and cut
it with 10 kilos of
heroin it started to decline over the
years decline decline decline decline
decline until until it got to a point
where you couldn't even cut it no more
the heroin they can't cut it no more um
because they'll make it weak so some
brilliant some I don't know who got the
brilliant idea to Purdue farmer I blame
too to come up with a
fentor fentor was designed originally
for a patch for cancer patients some
smart guy took it and put it in a white
powder and
so 50 times stronger 100 times stronger
than heroin yeah nobody don't want the
heroin no more now they want the fat no
and it's cheaper than
heroin and but but but I'm hearing that
they also starting
to lace
marijuana with um
VOR out there that's a problem that's a
big problem because you're going to
they're GNA these these they're going to
take guys who never even did opiates are
you going to give okay they shouldn't be
smoking marijana but they do and they're
going to have a opiate problem before
they know it and not even realize that
they have a problem but that is the main
drug is is is is is the meth the meth
and the fany that's the main things did
you have a question yes thank you I if I
can Mr chairman I have like a
three-point question we're working on
bail reform and um it's it's very
complex but my question is one of the
bills that we're working on um is uh
regarding you know testing drugs do in
your experience um do addicts take the
time to test their drugs for f thank you
how much they also we also considering
um legalizing um um minuscule amounts of
narcotic to to transport to a center to
test and they're talking about a 20
milligram so if an addict purchases
their drugs um brings it to a center to
test it for fentanyl you're not seeing
that in real life it's not going to
happen and thank you and my last
question is um do you feel that if we
close the borders we'll decrease the
amount of drug absolutely thank you the
second question uh the last question is
absolutely 1,00% the other two questions
the first two questions goes to this I'm
deeply sorry to inform you this but I'm
sorry you're wasting your time doing
that you really are you're going to be
wasting everybody's time and breath and
energies talking about trying to get
them to go They're not going to do that
and and not only that here's the other
problem I believe you're if you do that
you're going to enable them you're going
to make the problem worse by doing that
because at that point you're telling
them okay goad go get high just don't
o go steal just don't o you're going to
make the problem worse if you start
doing if you start to cater to the drug
dealer to as far as if we're going to
cater them we're going to cater to them
to get them off the drugs and give them
an alternative to incarceration or you
go to jail end the story do it on your
own or we'll help you do it
but if you start to cater to them trust
me listen to what I'm telling you please
you have to believe me when I'm telling
you this I beg you I'll get on my knes
if you want me to I beg you I come from
a lowincome area my whole life I've been
involved I Chang I got I went away in
2001 I came out 2011 and I've changed my
life but before that I was deeply
embedded in the street life I was a pro
drug
dealer I had an federal investigation
here one time and I shake the feds I am
smart I know how to do this if I was if
I was I would never do that but let's
just say if I went back to drug dealing
I would never get
arrested that's and I'm saying this
because I want you to understand the
magnitude of how that I know what I'm
saying if you start to entertain the
thought of in of of letting them indulge
in drugs you're going to make the
problem worse facts that is a fact you
will thank you representative um Harry
gther oh oh represent wheeler I'm sorry
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr Lopez
for your enthusiastic testimony um I
know the life that you're talking about
more than I think you understand and I I
guess my question would be when you're
talking about um trying to instill
instill this fear in people who are
selling drugs
um is that worth the mandatory minimum
uh uh sweeping up the people who are not
necessarily the cartel drug dealers I
mean when we're talking about and let me
just finish my question here when we're
talking about the cartels Purdue
Pharma The Entity that Fels coming from
I mean these are large entities with a
lot of money and are picking up their
street level dealers and putting them in
jail for 10 years is that necessarily
going to stop that industry and then is
that worth
picking up the people who aren't a part
of that industry who have just gotten in
such a bad way that they're now on the
street dealing drugs and now are in
prison for 10 years is that Culture of
Fear uh necess well a number one is that
going to actually stop this problem of
this uh I mean what is Evil coming from
this very well-funded Force being put
out on our streets I don't think so but
I'd like to hear hear what you think
about that and then B is it worth the
culture of fear and potentially picking
up people who aren't a part of that and
have just found themselves in a bad way
like yourself who uh given the right
opportunities in prison or out of it may
find themselves in a different and more
better
place absolutely it
work the first answer to your question
is yes we can't go after the cartels we
can't do nothing on a federal level DC
level but I'm not worried about that I'm
not worried about them worried about
this state and as a state yes it does
work because
there's 50 more 49 more if you take and
you lock lock it up in this state you
sew up this state you will deter drug
dealers from coming to this state to
sell drugs the way they don't like going
to main so if you have if you're
familiar with that which I think you I
think you are probably I think you are
are if you're familiar with that and you
have family that you know from that
life then you would know a lot of people
don't go to main for that reason they
don't go to main you go you got to be
crazy to go to Main and minimum
mandatories do
work um it was it was some it was a
certain group in local government and or
federal government that never lived that
lifestyle oh my God you can't put him in
jail that oh my God P him no yes you can
put him in jail that long they're
violating crimes they're killing people
with the crap they're selling you
goddamn right put them in jail minimum
mandatories 10 years that will work and
as far as the addicts like I said the
addicts don't deserve the 10 years the
addicts deserve help the ones who
deserve the 10 years are the ones that
are out there trying to be the
baller the
baller selling in kilos and this and
buying a kilo then doing that buying
houses in Dominican Republic buying
houses in Puerto Rico or buying a
mercedesbenz buying $3,000 gold chains
those are the ones that I'm talking
about that need to be put underneath the
jail you know
and
um I'm glad you said that you know
because because yeah I don't I'm not
concerned about it on a federal level
I'm not concerned about the cartels
DC got to worry about them Washington
you know you you know who uh
um Lindsey Graham and his crew they
worry about them they got a bill right
now they trying to they trying to
designate them as for terrorist
terrorist groups and if they do they're
going to go into Mexico and they're
going to kick
ass so we can't do that here I'm talking
about what we could do here on the state
level see what I'm saying so that's why
I'm going with that representative Road
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question Mr Lopez you had said
you went to prison for 10 years yes
right that was in New Hampshire well
part New Hampshire and then I went to
federal prison I have two sentences okay
and if I may
ask you said that you you no longer live
that lifestyle no thank you for that
don't even think about it I couldn't
even stomach well you're you're to be
commended for your for your alteration
thank you and my question specifically
is what
happened like where was the where was
the switch when did you what happened to
make you turn the
switch was when I was in conquer State
Prison and I took a pgd
test and they couldn't even score me
they couldn't even give me a it was a
five-part test and you got to you you
got to score 20 2,250 points 2250 two
pass and the top score is
3,000 I did so bad there was no score
for me nothing they couldn't even score
me I could it was a UT failure so um
when I saw that like I felt one day that
happened I felt like every bone in my
body
broke uh and I went into like this
depression I I still remember I was in I
was in h building
in coner State Prison I was on C CER and
for like a week I was so depressed and
there was a guy up there who worked at
the education he was a civilian his name
was Ed he had glasses I forget his last
name and uh he saw me one
day and he had like tears coming out his
eyes in the yard he had like tears
coming out he tells me you know you have
so much burning desire in you you could
be you could be such a good person and I
want to help you why don't you come to
the school and let me help
you and I was just so defeated by my GD
sore and I was just like so can't do it
I can't do it can't do it happened a
long time ago so nobody could get in
trouble no more but he told me listen if
you come to the school I'll bring you
food from the outside every Friday but
you can't miss one day throughout the
week if you miss one day you don't get
the McDonald's or whatever it is you
want from the
outside and and he persuad me to do it
and then he started to show me how to
read he show me a dictionary how to
pronounce words and I had a Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday word
and so if if bookshelf was my Friday
word then bookshelf in my head all day
bookshelf bookshelf so learn how to
spell it use it use put um spell it in
my head spell it in my head I want to
put my book on my bookshelf and just
just learning words like that and
then came like three and a half
years he tells me I think you're ready
for a GD so it wasn't like I had a
learning disability or anything like
that just I didn't care I was raised the
wrong way I was raised into selling
drugs and doing bad things I wasn't
supposed to be
doing and when he when he said you ready
for the GD test I was bubble guts are
you sure they said yes I took the GD
test when the score came back get ready
for my score
2750 I almost Ted it Jane Copeland was
the prison Warden at the time that was
before the Escape that was before Bruce
catel took over Jane Copeland
had a small little party for me up there
at the at the prison bought me cake ice
cream sodas and invited a few of the
guys from the education and came over
maybe like 20 people and had a had a
little party for me congratulations
party and that's how I and when I got
out you know I just I I changed my life
I'm that's it no more like it was a
spiritual awakening almost so to
speak like you know something took over
and I got out and then I started trying
to help the
community um helping people detox this
that there was a I'm I'm real good
friends with Anette Escalante she's like
the vice president of um or vice
president yeah vice president of the
farum center and at one time the farum
center people would wait three weeks
before they get a bed space and people
were dying left and right and so I felt
I had to do something about it and
that's when I had the detox place and
stuff like in my own garage and stuff
like that
and there was another I don't want to
say his name but he was another he was
one of your colleagues right he's he's
in government he told me your heart's in
the right
place but I'm scared I'm worried for
your safety why what do you mean they're
not going to do anything to me they love
me no if somebody dies there you could
be brought up on charges you're not
licensed to do that you're not a physici
you're not and so I stopped doing it I
was I got scared that somebody would
have passed away but I was trying trying
to help him you know he said they could
they could be they could be coming off
of alcohol and and opiates and or benzos
and or they could sneak something in
your house do it in your house and then
die in your garage then what
so lot of lot lot of lot of light bulbs
went under my head and I I didn't want
to stop help I didn't want to stop
helping them but I had to sorry I went
down the wrong that's all right thank
you unfortunately in our society often
uh no good deed goes unpunished
um any other further questions from the
committee
members well you are the um and it's
very it's a tragedy to say this you are
the only citizen that reached out to us
to uh to want to speak on this and I'm
glad that you actually came we heard
hundreds of hours of testimony from um
experts and um someone who actually
lives in the community and sees it dayto
day um are the reason we're here in the
first place we're not here considering
these bills because um someone from
within the criminal justice system said
we need to we're here because of the
public outcry has said we've had enough
something needs to change and the fact
that you came forward um is to be
commended and we I thank you very much
for coming if I could just add just one
more thing so um like I know that
there's people that never lived that
lifestyle you know went to good Ivy
League schools and this and that and the
ones that I say can't change the problem
and I hate to I hate to you put it like
but that's it's logic you can't argue
logic it's
true um I know that heart means very
well and they they they they put they
put that best foot forward into some of
these ideas that they put but they're
not the pros with the when it comes to
the ideas the pros are people like
myself maybe this guy over here who
people who live in in in in low in
communities he look like he comes from a
big city you you wasn't born in New
Hampshire was you oh I was born in King
New Hampshire oh look at the S fooled me
in the but you know but what I'm saying
is what I'm saying is a lot of people a
lot of
people don't come and speak because a
lot of people don't have hope no more
they lost hope they think that oh you're
wasting your time I you know I try to
get people to come with me today and
they give me excuses I got to work I got
to this oh you're wasting your time you
wasting your time they don't care they
don't care because this is what it has
become
in lowincome
areas this is what is this is what they
believe nobody
cares that there's no hope in a lot of
these areas no more and especially Union
Street you know you you drive down Union
Street listen you don't you don't have
to go home and watch The Walking Dead
just go stay sit on Union
Street in
Manchester you're going to see it you're
going to see it you're going to see
and you know what in Manchester in right
on Union Street there's a basketball
court I would love to see a little sub
police station go up
there a little sub police station go up
there they got one on the west side
where it's not needed where nothing
happens for who they got one on the west
side on Kelly Street where nothing
happens the heights nothing happens up
there but where where where where where
where where everything is happening they
have
nothing this is why the people from that
Community give up and they say you know
what they don't care because look they
got a substation over there where
nothing happens but over here where we
live where all the action is they don't
got
nothing another thing I want to add real
quick you guys I want to write this down
Abby coet Manchester
PD Abby coet Abby coet Manchester PD
she is phenomenal one
day on Bridge
Street this is why I say this there was
there was fire fire fire crew was there
and ambulance was there
and OD that's what comes to my head
right away and I like to keep the
statistic I like to wait what happened o
anyway so I went to Abby coet and I went
up to
her and I said hey can I get a minute
with you
sure they said what happened here is
this is this like an old or something
she took the time instead of telling me
this is we're doing go over there like
most police do go over there go over
there she took the time and she
explained it to me she couldn't explain
it all in one breath and told me hold on
wait a minute if you want to know more
just go over there I'll get back to you
and I did that to see if she would have
got back to me just uh because another
thing that's important is police and the
community they got to start start to get
along again right now they're not
getting along so I did that to see and
sure
enough before she got back in that
Cruiser she walked back
over she asked me if I had any more
questions that she could that she could
answer
me and I told her no I don't you know I
just wanted to see if you would really
come back and see if you were going to
answer any questions that I may have had
and I'm going to drop your names to some
people up there because you are true
policing in community and and if they
ever did a program where they train
police
officers public relations with the
community you should head that Abby coet
should be the head of that because
she's thank you uh Linda uh excuse me
represent Catherine have a
question thank you Mr chair um Mr Lopez
have you had a discussion with the chief
of police for Manchester or with your
mayor or with your Council folks I'm
just curious I try to reach out to The
Madam mayor so many times Jo Joyce Craig
she never responds back put it this way
her okay um follow up I'm sorry she
doesn't though she she Joyce
Craig that's how she has me right so
many things I reached out to her about
good things she never reaches out to
me yes what about your city council
I don't know who he is the only ones
that I do know is is
is is uh they're not even on um Pat long
I know a few guys but they can't help me
I know Pat long he's an older man I know
Joe Kelly he doesn't care I know Lou
delandro he doesn't care uh uh Dan Fels
he was not here no more I don't think
and that's all that I know for
government
body and I know you guys
now I like my friend over there I'm G
I'm going to reach out to him more okay
and your chief of
police no I have not reached out to him
um see here's the thing I've tried I've
made attempts in the past but what
happens is they take a message they
don't respond to
you they don't respond to
you thank you I would love to talk to
the chief of police and give him some
ideas you know again again I want to say
this I'm not the sharp his knife in the
jawer I'm not I'm not saying that and
I'm not here to say that I'm not here to
say hey what I say is what what I say
was what works and that's it and that's
not what I'm saying I'm here to help I'm
here to give you
everybody my
experience what what I know would work
in these communities these low-income
communities because this is where I grew
up my entire
life this is where I grew up my entire
life if you take me if she took me to to
her let's just for example let's just
just just make pretend okay she has a
beautiful
home beautiful and suburbia like if she
took me up there I'd be dumb I wouldn't
know what to
do because I've never lived that I don't
know if I'm making sense but I've never
lived that life I would be
lost so it's those very same people you
can't fix my world you can I'm sorry I
don't mean to be I don't mean to be I'm
not I'm not being rude and I'm not being
cocky or I'm not being anything we're
being we're speaking Logics these are
facts you can't you can't solve my you
can't solve these problems you need you
need people from this community from
this side of the
tracks you're you guys you guys are the
you guys are the people who sit at the
throne that can make the
changes with the input from these people
here
make sense you can make the changes you
have the power to make the changes but
you need the input from the people from
this side of the tracks and and again
I'm going to say one more time drug
dealers if you are selling drugs in this
state and you are a Cold Stone
coldhearted drug dealer not an addict
and I don't care if you do cocaine and
smoke weed you're not an addict in my
opinion you're not an addict you got to
be a
every you got to be an opiate
addict write legislation just like
Robert Bley wrote the RICO law you apply
this I'll help you I'll write it for you
in my own language you can put it in
legislative languages I'll do it for you
put it and it applies to drug dealers
and drug dealers only it's the same
thing Robert Blakeley did to Target the
mafia why we can't do the same statue to
Target drug dealers why what's so hard
about that it's not hard it's easy let's
get together let's get in a room let's
write legislation put it on the floor
let's talk to let's get get sun the
passor sign it into law we have our own
drug trafficking so to speak like RICO
Act in New Hampshire but that applies to
drug dealers but it has the same
principles sheares the same principles
and of a RICO statute but it applies
to uh uh fentor heroin and opiate
dealers true dealers not
addicts if you if if you went and bought
heroin for somebody and you took it to
somebody and you got somebody the deal
for yourself and you did it you're not
you're not a dealer at that point I'm
sorry you're
incarceration otherwise let's not do
nothing and 20 years from now 15 years
from now we'll be having the same
discussion again and I'll just be
older thank you and I think that's a
perfect not a to end on and um uh that
will be and I also think it was um very
timely that this is uh the last of the
um testimony we'll be taking after this
we'll be sitting down to um write
whatever we're going to do so we
appreciate you very much thank you for
having me I thank everybody thank you
thank you with that we are Clos for the
you
thank